Hi everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at the baking tool inside of Niagara.
So let's get started.
In Unreal, we have the ability to use tools to bake our effects.
So they're great, especially for items from a distance.
So keep that in mind because it does keep things lighter, but there is a breakdown resolution-wise.
So you kind of want to keep these in the distance, so they can't be helpful.
The only thing you can really run into here that you also have to be careful with is how
your loop is run.
Now for obvious reasons, a liquid effect, a fog effect, a particle effect is not going
to loop exactly.
So you want to make sure when you set it, how long your duration speed, or I should say
duration seconds, are going to be.
Now this baker, let's go and look at it in Unreal, is again, it's pretty new and it
can be kind of experimental, but you can also run the option of exporting your images,
which I mentioned from the last lecture, high resolution EXR and put them on a plate
and make it so that there's an alpha involved.
But you can also use this one, which again, can be used, but for things in the distance,
and you want to make sure you know exactly how long that shot's going to be.
If you're using ICB effects, in case and point, if you know how long that shot's going to
be, you can match up your effect to know when it's actually going to come to an end.
Otherwise, a loop is going to run into some trouble.
So let's go ahead and jump into Unreal and take a look at that.
So here in Unreal, I have the effect up front.
This is grabbing, and I just positioned my camera a certain way in the baker, which I'll
show you.
But you can see this is actually a pretty decent effect, but it is very short, and it
being very short, you have to determine what you want from this effect and how long your
seconds are going to be.
You also need to keep in mind how things are getting cut off.
How big in your original effect is your bounding box, your scale.
And you'll notice here on this fire effect kind of comes to a ceiling.
So if I wanted to, I could open this up a little bit.
But again, like I mentioned before, you need to consider your resolution because as you
make the scale bigger for that effect, your resolution could take a hit and you could
get some pixelation.
But in the case of baking and it's in the distance, you may not have to worry about
that as much because you really are just trying to give the illusion of something.
And this actually, this one came out pretty good.
But again, it is very short.
So let's go ahead and take a look at this effect up close.
What we can do is do the same effect when it comes to the fire.
So let's go and double click on this guy.
And we'll go to the baker here.
So let's open up the baker.
So the baker is going to show me kind of a low level version of what I have.
And it's actually not too bad in this particular case.
But you will see in here that you do need to make sure you take an account how you
position your camera.
That's very important.
So you want to make sure that it's centered.
If it isn't centered, you could run into the problem of things not being able to be
looking like you want.
You'll get some bad clipping.
So what I mean by that, if we left click, we can move our camera around this 3D space.
And this will drag left click and drag allow us to be able to position things like we want.
Another one you can do is middle click and drag to pan.
So if I middle mouse click, I can pan back and forth to get the right positioning.
And then we also can right click and drag to zoom.
So if I right click, I can zoom in and out on this effect.
And may get a pretty decent look visually for my output.
Now, again, you also need to keep in mind the size that you're outputting when you
decide to use this baker.
Also click F to center the frame.
So if I click in here and keep my finger on the F key, I can center on the effect.
Now we're a little bit too close.
So we're going to have to move back a little bit there.
So let's go in wheel mouse there and a little back and try actually right mouse there.
And middle mouse to get that positioning.
So you have to keep those things in mind when you're actually baking these that things
are not getting cut off because they will easily get cut off if you're not careful.
And again, you can see the top of my bounding box being hit by the smoke.
So you also need to take an account your size, which I mentioned or scale,
which I mentioned earlier.
So in the settings, which we'll talk about in Unreal and go back and forth
with the slides, we have to make sure we take an account our perspective or
or throw front positioning or throw back.
So you can literally punch these numbers in, but you can also control your texture
size too.
You do need to take an account what this spreadsheet is going to be.
Because in this case, you want to make sure that your dimensions are of the equal
size to what you want this to be.
Because honestly, it's going to make a little spreadsheet for you and you have
to do that math.
So for ideal behavior, you want to set your textures size to a power of two and
the frames per dimension to be a number that divides evenly into that texture
size.
Let me show you what I mean.
In this one that I've already created, you can actually see a just a quick
glimpse of this particular effect.
I did it from a side view, which I thought worked pretty nice.
But you want to make sure that in your Atlas texture size, and again, here we
have the, the live sim and the big sim.
You can do a comparable.
We want to make sure that we increase the resolution to our needs.
Now, if it's way in the distance, you could probably get away with doing 128.
But in our case, we might want it a little bit higher so we could do a 512.
Now the problem with the 512 is you're going to bump up your resolution
dramatically.
Notice we went to 496.
We also can turn off our playback here in the regular mode and just make it so
that's just running through our Baker sim.
And you can see it playback here down below compared to over here, which is
going to eat up a bit of memory.
Now that's pretty high.
We probably don't need 4096.
So we could probably do 256.
Nicely, it does a bit of the math for us, but you want to keep this again in a
power of two, like mentioned before.
Let's switch back to our gas fire here and let's actually make a bake for this
particular asset.
Now, again, we're going to follow the same rules here and we're going to change
your resolution to 256.
Now, when I set this to 256 by 256, again, the resolution increases, but you
also want to make sure that the, there is a wrap in here.
This is what I find to be the best options to choose from.
You can go in here and change these to clamp or mirror the effect if you want
to, but we're going to keep that as a wrap.
So you'll see there's also the out, the Atlas asset path format.
Let's actually pause this playback here for a second.
The Atlas asset path format here.
So we've chosen this particular area where it's going to output.
Now you'll notice if you scroll down just a little bit, there's a frame
asset path format we could use too, as well as a frame export path format.
So these also can be assets that you want to send out the door and reference
them as you need them.
And you'll be able to have those assets for you as a backup.
One thing I do want to point out too is your frames per dimension.
If you don't have these high enough, things can get choppy and won't look as
smooth, but if you have them too high based on your resolution,
things also can get pixelated.
So there's kind of a give and take with that.
So let's go and run this bake simulation.
Now it's going to make a baker folder for you when you do it.
You'll notice there's warnings here.
It says a midder gas control is not set to deterministic results.
We'll vary each bake.
So what this means when you're working with your asset is that we need to go
into the emitter itself and go to determinism here.
And this is going to make sure we get the same results with the same effect here.
And that should get rid of that issue.
Now you may run into some with new versions of the effect.
If you import it, if you've got new version of Unreal and you get bringing it
to your scene, you may run into some of these issues where you'll get like,
hey, this is different now.
This may give you weird results to keep that in mind.
So I turned on the determinism.
It should actually make that error go away.
So let me go ahead and fix this particular issue where it says GPU is incorrectly
running particle update script on the particle spawn.
Now we had a couple of these.
This is the first one that I fixed.
I'm going to the second one.
And this is due to the previous GPU code gen.
So be careful though.
When you turn these on, you could actually make your effect not work anymore.
And that just means something has been disconnected.
This doesn't mean it's completely a wash that you can't use it.
It just means you may have to go in there and fix a couple of these issues that
may be persisting because of it.
But again, I turned on the determinism here and that should fix some of the issues.
And I simply looked it up into my effect.
And we go ahead and fix this issue here.
There we go.
Fire is coming back.
Now, for some reason, you do fix an issue and it's still giving you issue,
still giving you a problem.
You can hit control Z and try to live with it and see if you can manage it.
Just be careful with that because if you have a lot of dependencies,
that could become an issue.
Now, you'll notice that error has gone away, which is fantastic.
Let's actually check the other one too, because he was kind of the problem in the
baker.
Let's go to his baker.
I may have closed it.
Let me see here.
Go to the baker tab.
There it is.
Yep.
It went away.
Fantastic.
It's gone.
So you can see that can actually clear that up pretty easily.
So we have this here.
Let's go and run this bake at 256.
Now, again, you can go higher like you saw me do.
We can go to 4k even.
Let's turn off that playback again, because that is eating a bit of memory.
And let's go ahead and make this up.
You have to give it a little bit of time.
It'll pixelate it first and then it will kick in.
I paused it just in case things I had too many processes going in the background.
But it's actually not too bad.
That's pretty good.
Let's go and take a look at this material and how this works on the other side of
things.
So I went to my content folder here and just typed in baker.
Probably should have been a little more specific where to put it, but you can
actually see that it's made individual files too.
If I needed it.
So that's actually pretty handy.
So that's secondary control.
If we go to it really quick in Unreal, looking at our window, you'll actually
see here again, you can do individual assets if you need to.
Plus you can also do it for the Atlas if you need to.
So that's pretty handy if you wanted to edit them and tweak them after the fact.
You have that option.
You can add more to it if you needed to, or take it into an editing software like
Photoshop.
You can actually do a little bit of adjusting.
So back in my content folder here.
We'll take a look here.
Again, you can see the individual assets, but let's look at the Atlas here.
And this actually came out pretty nice.
Pretty decent resolution.
Again, you do see the top where it hits.
So you've got to be aware of that when you're building these effects.
Again, where your box begins and ends on your object.
Now connecting this to the materials, what we need to do next and to be able to
place it where we need to place it.
Before we fully jump into that, I want to make sure I point out a few things.
You'll notice that there was a source binding at the top.
Make sure that's set to none.
And again, you can choose your scene color HDR values if you want to when
generating your texture, and you can determine where that texture is going to
be plus the size, which we talked about the size control.
You can also show where that's going to end up.
It will see a texture graphic in our slides, but in this case, you can
actually just simply click on the magnifying glass and you'll see where
Atlas is loaded.
Pretty nice and pretty convenient.
And again, the frames paths can also be adjusted and where you want those to lie.
Now, just remember, if you generate a new one, it's going to be replaced
unless you designate where that new one is going to be at.
If you don't, it will simply just right right over it.
That's it with this one.
In the next video, we're going to go ahead and set up the material and the
particle and connect those all together to get the flipbook to work.
Thanks again.